julie from southern minnesota let's hear
from julie
this is a good question hi my name is
julie
from southern minnesota my question is
what advice do you have for a person
who's on a fixed income about
40 pounds overweight so nobody ever
guesses me
at my current weight of 180
um and with a knee that's been giving me
problems because i'm now
51 and arthritis has decided
to take up residence in my knee
so any suggestions um
obviously i don't want to be a elite
athlete but i do want to take up running
that is one of my
dreams and goals and
so i'm just wondering um
she'd give me a cliff notes version
of how i work up to that
otherwise i'm in good health just chubby
with a bad knee
thank you hi julie
thank you for your question that's a
good question a dream of becoming a
runner
i like it and i appreciate and applaud
your
your honesty um first of all i'd say i'm
not a doctor
so i'm not in a position to give you
medical advice with respect to your
arthritis and your knee so i don't know
exactly what's going on with your knee
and i i'm reluctant to
you know say anything that's gonna um
exacerbate whatever's going on there so
the first thing is i would
go to the doctor and figure out exactly
what's going on there
what you can and you can't do so that
whatever activity you do
take up isn't going to make that knee
problem worse
to the extent that it's manageable my
best suggestion for you is to
get out and go for a walk these things
start with that
right you're on a fixed income doesn't
cost anything
to go out and walk you don't need to buy
fancy shoes you don't need to buy
anything all you need to do is put one
foot in front of the other
and if you ask any of the people that
i've had on the podcast who have
gone from being severely overweight to
becoming ultra runners people like
joshua johnny
it started with a walk around the block
right and you just build
very gradually upon that so
that's my only and best suggestion is to
just begin
whatever excuses you're telling yourself
about what you can and you can't do
are keeping you paralyzed and stuck on
the couch
and it really doesn't have to be
anything that's scary or onerous
than that initial walk and then after
you've been doing that
a little bit and you walk a little bit
further and you walk a little bit
farther
maybe try to jog for 10 or 15 yards and
see how that feels
and then the next day you go a little
bit longer and you stay on top of that
knee
and you ice it and you go to the doctor
and you eat
foods that are healing that are
anti-inflammatory that are anti
high in antioxidants and the weight will
start to drop gradually this isn't like
a crash
diet thing or a situation where you're
going to snap your fingers and your
life's going to change overnight
this is a lifestyle shift the idea is
you want to make this shift
that has staying power that helps you
fall in love
with movement that brings joy into your
life by virtue
of exercising your body so that it
becomes an embedded
habit and the easy choice rather than
the hard choice so walk out the door
walk around the block celebrate the
small wins
start to make tweaks small tweaks in
your diet
and as you start to see very gradual
results
you'll experience what we talked about
at the beginning of this podcast with
respect to goals
you'll start to feel more emotionally
attached to this journey
more invested in it you'll develop that
momentum
and before you know it it will become a
self-perpetuating
motion machine that's going to take you
on an amazing journey
i like it and physical therapy can also
help with a knee sometimes and to get
advice from physical therapists
would be something i'd recommend help me
with a really bad foot for a long long
time
and if you so if you haven't explored
physical therapy you can usually get
that even on a fixed income you can
usually
get that with your health coverage
whatever that may be yeah if you're if
you're if your insurance covers that
great
beyond the physical therapy and and
going to the doctor about your knee
the grand total cost of this experiment
is zero dollars right i love it um
and i remember when i was first getting
back into running after being
on the shelf with that foot problem for
a year
uh started with five minutes running
five minute walks
you know you like a fartlek type thing
but not at a high intensity
is that something you recommend to yeah
yeah yeah i'm a big believer in that
yeah yeah run walks
[Music]
you